hello freak [ __ ] [ __ ] if we if
you are if you are a globalist an
internationalist like I am if you
basically believe you're a globalist
that's a negative thing but I know I
only got it I've only started using that
term lately because the old right thinks
that globalism is like this Jewish you
know global conspiracy and I love Allah
so I'm trying to take over the world
I'm an omen I'm an open-minded person so
I think what I would hide it well I
would define it as being someone who
doesn't like borders and who doesn't
like nationalism and jingoism and
believes that we are all one and should
try to get along you know what I hear
bro I hear New World Order that's what I
hear this [ __ ] new world order
a cherry we have on the show frightened
camps is that one it was an Alice Jones
impression was getting close wasn't it
Alex Jones as a performance artist is
that what you claim you know what I
asked people on Twitter what I should
ask you and overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly it's all like why does he
legitimate quacks like Alex Jones really
don't equivalence problem oh no no no no
why did you have to do so many bad by
factors like Alex Jones how many people
don't interview like Alex Jones yeah
first of all I don't interview anybody
not interviewing you am i no I'm not an
interviewer I suck at that I kind of
interviewed Ron Miscavige yesterday I
talked to people and I record it sit not
journalists by any stretch of the
imagination Alex Jones been my friend
for 20 years he's [ __ ] crazy
I showed everybody how crazy was on my
podcast by getting him high and drunk
and having to talk about
interdimensional child molesters if you
watch that and you think I'm
legitimizing Alex Jones some sort of a
way then you're just you're you just
you're looking at things in a very
cookie cutter way you're deciding that
this is what I've done but a lot of
people listen to you and so I think the
criticisms these people have is like
people put faith in in you and they
assume that if you don't raise a
question against something that that
means that that you tacitly agree with
what's being said and that that allows
you know the revelation of the questions
about Alex why don't know I didn't
listen to your identity raised questions
but we were more bullshitting than
anything and having fun and he was
hammered
I mean people got a chance to see him
they're actually using footage of the
conversation that we had against him in
his custody battle
because they're saying he was in Los
Angeles on film smoking marijuana he's a
loose cannon and that's the literally
being here against AB he doesn't you
don't give a [ __ ] they asked him any
battle he asked him a question about
kitty couldn't rumors are I had a large
bowl of chili for lunch today he's
[ __ ] crazy he's crazy and he makes
ridiculous amounts of money absolutely
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's a great guy
I swear to god he's a great guy okay
it's just he's just got a ridiculous
platform and he's kind of character hmm
but he that's who he is man
you think he's a performance house I
think there is a part of what he does
that is most certainly theater I think
anybody doesn't try go this guy goes out
taqueria Todd comes out it's been
impression gonna work on it almost as
bad as my Trump impression fortunately I
never listened to Ellis Jones so I don't
know what he I mean I see clips of him
when someone shares something with me
online but like it lasts too short to
listen to Alex Jones the best clips or
when he gets mad he apologizes I'm a
Christian sorry I have to say though he
comes on one someone said something
about him recently and he went all I
never swear 20 years of nurse Warren on
the air but this [ __ ] [ __ ] he is
[ __ ] crazy I didn't like that and I'm
sorry I'm sorry I apologize on a
children listen this is wrong I mean
he's [ __ ] he's a maniac I'm not
giving him I'm not giving him legitimacy
he already has a massive platform
arguably bigger than mine what I'm doing
is showing you what I see what I hang
out with Alec shows people like why you
friends with Alex Jones like he's a nice
guy
I like him look I have a friend do I
argued with for a [ __ ] hour yesterday
thinks I'm pretty sure he thinks the
[ __ ] world is flat yeah that's
another one that I got satellite if any
Bravo yeah he thinks satellites aren't
real he doesn't believe in dinosaurs he
thinks dinosaurs are [ __ ] he doesn't
believe in nuclear bombs he's out to
lunch he doesn't believe in nuclear
bombs listen man you can't you can't
even hold it to the fire it's it's
ridiculous I don't understand his
thought process and again I've been
friends with him as long as I've been
friends Alex Jones it had weight closer
with Eddie way closer Eddie's one my
best friend huh huh he's [ __ ] crazy
but if you talk to me about conspiracies
but if you talk to him about like MMA or
he's a jujitsu genius he's like one of
the very best jujitsu instructors on the
planet earth without a doubt the meanest
comes back again to the like how we can
compartmentalize our minds right like a
religious person who believes in the
story of Jesus but is also otherwise
super intelligent that's a perfect
analogy yeah yeah it's it's and you know
I don't know how people's brains work I
don't understand I you know I've I've
tried to study like peoples really
irrational thinking and try to but you
know what I worry more than anything I
worried that it's a contagious disease I
think it is
[Applause]
[Music]